hi I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome back
to New rockstars the first day of Black
History Month in Disney releases black
panther wakanda forever for streaming I
was able to take a closer look at
everything and then the re-release
breakdown which is this video right here
I'm going to talk about the pieces we
missed the first time around so boss did
the original breakdown along with 20
more Easter eggs found video so I'll be
pointing out things I found that weren't
in those two videos so if there's
something you're like Jessica you missed
this nope no I didn't boss already
touched on it but no need to worry I've
got you all covered and I'm so excited
to dive in this again with new release
information that we didn't really get in
November so let's get into it and also
first we're gonna spoil I'm about to
spoil a lot of things so you better have
seen the movie before I do this we
opened the movie as we know with the
death of our Beloved t'challa the doors
open and we're facing the back of shuri
this elevator will get a better look at
later it's a hover elevator built on set
in the center of the lab in the first
movie it was like a spiral staircase
clearly the difference between Sherry's
lab in the first movie and now are
pretty drastic but I think the elevator
could be implemented not only for faster
arrival but may be more accessible as
t'challa was getting sicker everyone is
clearly in a rush but not Sherry I think
as everyone is working and it's clear
that t'challa is not going to make it
and they're mourning their King while
Sherry refuses to mourn her own brother
Rio voiced by Trevor Noah is shuri's new
AI but the name Rio in West African is
the Storyteller singer musician and oral
historian the griot keeps records of all
the births deaths marriages throughout
the generation of the village I'm sure
he's not wearing the kamoyo bead
earrings that she's wearing later I
think this shows that once her brother
left she really hit herself in her
studies when most of the pouring of
libations for someone that's passed away
pop culture media and even comedy has
given as many references to pouring one
out but the ACT goes back to ancient
cultural Traditions from Roman Greek and
even African its way to show honor and
recognize that the person is still among
us we didn't touch heavily on their
wardrobe the first time around seeing as
interviews with Ruth Carter the costume
designer didn't come out until much
later after the movie was released in
theaters so I want to touch on that
inspiration a bit so Ruth Carter the
costume designer mentioned in an
interview with the rep we are so
intentional about how each person is
represented how each person celebrates
their culture she did a ton of research
and made sure you see the different
tribes represented in Africa you see the
Touareg of Mali represented the Zulu
tribe Baba Maul who's singing during the
funeral is wearing a white version of
the traditional West African clothing
this is all very important to Ruth not
only to learn but to celebrate the
people who make up this nation in the
MCU and in the real world in the wakanda
forever podcast she discusses how
changes between the costumes in Black
Panther 1 were severely altered this
time because they weren't made to get
wet Sam Williams does a great job at
architectural digest explained in the
landscape of wakanda and says wakanda is
a clear example of where nature and a
city can blend together and you can see
that solely off this funeral scene the
wall with all the flowers actually is a
koye's house confirmed in the production
designer's tweets inspired by the
actresses Zimbabwe Roots we referred to
this funeral as a celebration of life
which it is in the wakanda forever
podcast production designer Hannah
beechler referred to this as a jazz
funeral which it is it's a celebration
of the extension pull of chorus and
respect for the deceased as the Dora
melange I like that Angela Bassett says
Dora milage
I can't say that's cool asador melange
carry t'challa's coffin it's engraved
with wakanda forever rests with the
ancestors wakanda forever as the Black
Panther symbol crosses its chest we know
the mural done by Brandon Sadler reads
the panther king forever lives in us and
rests with the ancestors below it our
Easter eggs are Kirby beachler and other
designers names next to that we can't
really see it but there is a window with
a 3D printed replica building from the
comic books to the right we see the same
line pattern reminiscent of okoye's
tattoos on her head but next to that are
different miniature statues reflecting
different African tribal masks when we
see the amount of people morning
t'challa you get a serious glimpse of
the city of wakanda the patterns or
designs for each Building represent
different groups I personally looked at
it based off traditional African fabrics
and prints Ankara bogalan Latisse and
the traditional print when shuri has had
it and it lets her feelings out she
grips t'challa's casket and we see her
tattoo a bit but her tattoos aren't all
that new we see her Palm with the double
helix and in the first movie she had the
exact same tattoo I thought thought it
was new so this is just news to me I
guess in the script it says the aircraft
rockets off towards the Hall of Kings
where he will be laid to rest which is
where the heart-shaped herb was grown in
the first movie The Script being
released was a game changer originally
this intro with the clips of t'challa
would have Global reactions of people
mourning in the MCU clearly we see in
the finished project it's complete
silence which for me was much better
touch it's like having a moment of
silence around the world for him one
year later and we're at the United
Nations at the beginning you hear
romanda's jet engine purring off
because you just landed we haven't seen
much of the UN recently just reports of
them in the news and eternals and
Captain Marvel though basing this off
the Disney plus MCU timeline they put it
before She-Hulk so the sokovia Accords
could be off the table by this point I
say this only because technically no
more and wakanda are doing a ton of
damage remember that the sokovia cores
were basically implemented to watch
superheroes so no more innocent people
died in the crossfire and the more is
killing a ton of innocent people and
they think it's the wakandans now the
fact that France and I'm assuming the US
zetazuni is French name for the U.S and
he's wearing an American pin they're
fighting Amanda to take vibranium and
it's a big deal seen as the head of the
CIA is now Val what could this man at
the UN be doing in connection to Val who
dreams of having vibranium seems like
they're setting up some much needed
armor in the Thunderbolts or something
along those lines I believe the message
ramonda delivers everyone talking about
what kind of resources is also a direct
message to Val and the original script
the French secretary of state had a
little more to say that was taken out of
the final project she asked why is there
so much secrecy around this resource and
even criticizes why it's extended to
some groups and not the whole of France
U.S or even Belgium it's not like
they're giving it out they're not giving
it for free they're making Outreach
centers that's when Ramona claps back
which is truly is Chef kiss but
originally she started her monologue by
saying thank you Mr chairperson
wakanda's offerings to the global
Community do not begin and end with our
nation's most valuable resource but it
was edited out Queen ramonda's jewelry
around her neck did resemble the piece
no more give Sherry later both items are
made from vibranium I think it was
immediately a nod in contrast to two
very different women how their Origins
are similar they're so vast a migrant
Story versus someone who stayed two
queens in their own way in their own
separate worlds losing their Partners
bringing the strongest people into this
world and always protecting their kin
these two aren't too far off but the
origins hurdles and their outcomes are
completely different additionally this
outfit raimondo is wearing is actually
the outfit she was supposed to die in
but cougar chose it for the Unseen
instead she looks more strong
look at Angela bassett's arm she's
always strong the custom designer Ruth
Baker gets into this but truly how
powerful is it to enter something as big
as the UN not wearing a business suit
it's truly remarkable and already sets
up the hierarchy between them and the
wakanda queen additionally I want to
point out the Dora milage wear silver
but Okoye wears gold probably because
she's the general it's no surprise that
Ramona's speech is reflected and the
actions happening at the Outreach Center
in Mali she says we know what you
whisper in your Halls of leadership and
in your military facilities the king is
dead the Black Panther is gone opens a
black door nothing in sight unprotected
at the Outreach Center it's like they
lost already they have lost their
protector now is our time to strike
emerge as the door of melange from the
darkness the protectors we all want and
need 10 steps ahead of the game now is
the time to strike indeed follow
Ramona's speech and wishing them the
best of luck fighting vibranium were
taken to the Atlantic Ocean to a team of
deep sea mining technicians using their
own vibranium detector and they just
struck gold or black or purple or black
you know what I mean I love this shot
when Lake Bell enters and we meet Smitty
this is a harvey offshore support vessel
and notice how he's the center perch
right below the only light in the
darkest Ocean between the text Harvey
and sub he is the point of reference we
don't find this out but thanks to this
grip we can confirm Smitty is of the CIA
and directly works for Val another nod
to Bow storyline trying to get this
vibranium also Marvel loves making big
companies out to be the bad guy so good
to keep an eye out for Enviro plus these
diving suits look hella funny and if
you're like me a big dummy I assumed our
Tech would surpass these clunky giant
mechanical suits but these kind of
special suits which maintain internal
pressure in deep water equal to the
pressure on the surface are called
atmospheric diving suits or ads they're
aimed at the undersea oil rig workers
Salvage experts or scientists exploring
the ocean floor which is funny because
the man who created a suit like this in
real life compared it to an Iron Man
suit wow the saying goes I guess art
imitates life or life imitates art I'm
not smart we get a closer look at the
monitor checking the levels of the
divers along with the valve connected to
the drill also nice to note that the
vibranium detector found the vibranium
but the drill can't pierce it it got
chewed up it's also freaking huge I just
didn't imagine it the vibranium found in
the ocean floor is approximately 1 540
meters down so like over 5000 feet when
all hell breaks loose we get a glimpse
at the talokins as a unit they form this
perfect triangle like a V formation when
using their siren song The Sound was
originally supposed to be a cross
between a whale and a human with some
plane of an Ocarina now personally I'm
not here in Wales
[Music]
but that's just me I think it's more
tribal and ancient now I was going to
get into the outfit inspiration for the
teleconneal later but I'll just do it
now since they're introduced Ruth Carter
partnered with a lot of people one being
Paul Kang for original concept ideas
they aspired for hayam made Mayan Mosaic
look sticking to a lot of Jade for
jewelry like the ear spools pulling from
Mayan culture and things found in the
oceans originally they used organic
materials for Neymar's headdress but
then it floated away underwater a lot of
their wardrobe had to be updated keeping
in mind the water restrictions because
after it went in it wasn't reusable
because the chemicals that were in the
water before which was the same problem
The wakanda Outfits had and Ruth pulled
through looking amazing I also just love
a tuma's shark armor and the teeth
around his neck his design was so sick I
just love it we get a wakanda and aerial
shot with Baba Mall singing again this
time the song's titled wakanda
Anderson Cooper's voice Blair's
addressing Queen ramana's actions during
the UN meeting the ticker at the bottom
does read about Scott Lang's new book
but before that it says economies at an
unprecedented rate whether the beginning
says Regional or seasonal we don't know
it's cut off perfectly I also like that
even through Anderson Cooper's eyes we
see how people think of wakanda he calls
it the tiny Nation yes at least five
different tribes mountains Everglades
all
we see in a small so no one enters or
bothers them but it's definitely not
tiny also the ship's got a major upgrade
since we last saw it in Black Panther
the first movie it still has the same
mechanics flying as you see the orange
circles around okoye's wrist for
steering but the purple pattern and the
patterns on the side are much more bold
and I love it I also don't think we
witnessed them ever opening the River
border on the first movie so this is
good to add we get a close-up of this
board from the production designer's
tweet this is inspired by the liquindy
drumming of central Africa done by the
Baka women there's also eight River
barriers in wakanda and they represent
eight tribes of the omo Valley River
tribes in Ethiopia God I I just love
Hannah beachler the production designer
so much she goes in she also confirms
yes there's different entrances of
wakanda and the other tribe's monitor
which we see in the first movie with the
Border tribe I think that part just
sheds light on how easy it is to get
into wakanda and Which tribes can let
people in look at this beautiful
afrofuturistic city I love it we get a
glimpse of the train that we're also
quick to remember from the first movie
at the bottom of the screen you can tell
the lab looks a little different from
the first movie and this mural for the
elevator is created by Brandon Sadler
who did t'challa's mural in the Golden
City and doesn't griot just give off Hal
from 2001 Space Odyssey or is it just me
sure he is burying herself in science
again and she's working harder than ever
in Escape perhaps because it's been
exactly a year since the child is
passing I think it's important to note
when remonda says the Black Panther
unified their Nation for centuries I
alluded to later the next time we see
wakanda may be in Revolt and with the
Black Panther being in Haiti it might
feel like they still have no protector
we get into this morning ritual between
shuri and ramonda sitting at the
riverbank watching elephants dip into
the water we learned through press in
the wakanda forever podcast Ryan coogler
says this like the whole idea that first
screenplay was that
t'challa and tushant were doing
something that we call the ritual of
eight which is which is where the kid
turned eight years old he got to spend
eight days with his father in the bush
and during those eight days he could ask
his father any question that he wanted
and his father had to answer honestly
you know and so now it was like okay
well with that ritual was gone what
ritual are we gonna do for sure you know
how can I plan to her relationship who's
she doing ritual oh man which makes
sense for it to be reminded like that
that kind of thing and the ritual of
eight was changed to a different trial
in the final script the ritual of
mourning and moving on between Rwanda
and shuri Ryan coogler mentions this is
the whole movie Just because someone's
dead doesn't mean that they're gone
which clearly it's hard for sure a
realistic grapple with that when we
first see the fool no more it's sort of
dark so I'm gonna grab the best angle we
can see of him right when he kills
raimonda spoilers they did a good job
resembling him from the comics his
necklace is a two-headed serpent open
mouth and the middle is a pearl that
represents the water it turns out no
more does have many names and some of
which are spoken about on the wakanda
forever podcast they say this is a story
told about him becoming a king or Kahu
ahau of telecon and how is one with
allow loudest voice and not necessarily
a king he's also Kuka Khan Ryan has this
great way when it comes to villains of
giving them many names especially when
you're talking about indigenous people
because one way I think he felt that
they kind of keep you in a place as they
never let you settle with the name
that's why killmonger had so many names
and that's why nemour has so many names
as well again Hannah beechler and icon
interestingly in the original script the
shell was to be sound off near the coast
of Madagascar at a small spot called and
I'm probably gonna pronounce this wrong
I'm so sorry nosy nozinato which is
facing closer to the Indian Ocean so I
wonder if they decided to not address
the location or more specifically
confirm our fears though no more can get
to you at any time at any place an
astonishing speed this video is
sponsored by PayPal honey honey is the
number one online shopping tool but call
in an online shopping tool doesn't
really do it justice using Honeys like
having a little dude following you
around while you shop online whose whole
job is to help you save save money on
stuff you're already paying for and let
me tell you I need that honey
automatically searches for the promo
code so you don't have to it works for
lots of your favorite websites whether
you're looking for clothes food or video
games really if you could be spending
Less on it honey helps you spend less on
it it's ridiculously easy to use which I
like because I like things that are easy
to use it's also free which I like
because I like things that are free I'm
usually stealing things so this is good
for me which is probably why it's got
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews on Google but hang on in your
rush to get honey go to joinhoney.com
new rockstars because that's how you
help support this Channel or you know
just click the link in the description
below I know it's there go on go click
it when embaku enters the archway above
him on the right it says the wisdom of
our ancestors on the left it says on
sacred ground we may find there's a
little misprint boss notice later when
Okoye is pleading with raimonda but
during the ancestral plane scene it's
correct either way this wasn't there in
the first black panther film it's been
completely upgraded with gold and they
finally touch on it they address it
vibranium resides outside wakanda sure
he says this perhaps there was more than
one meteorite our planet is covered of
mostly water so it's reasonable that the
other one just landed there this changes
everything that we know akoy even
mentioned their stories in the fables
but that doesn't go against their own
stories remember in the first black
panther it was addressed millions of
years ago
a meteorite made
of the strongest substance in the
indestruct the continent of Africa but
that doesn't answer where the meteorite
came from and certainly doesn't answer
where the other media writes if more
than two landed we get a call back to
the first movie of our favorite
colonizer Everett Ross jog into Red Hot
Chili Peppers and I just think it's
really funny we have such tribal and
ancient music for the wakandans and
telekineal but Red Hot Chili Peppers for
some white guy
once they find Riri Williams at MIT
created the vibranium detector they
shoot down to Boston and look at these
two lordy also you know Lexus is still
their sponsor since that first movie
look at all them cars okoye's paranoid
her makeup isn't the right shade and
it's the greatest call out sure he says
this it's the wrong shade isn't it it's
the right sheet 2440 you look good
personally I'm shade 445 and I just
gotta say in Darker weather we could be
using the same product baby Mina koi or
Okoye genuinely is buying the wrong
shade of Fenty when Sherry gets the
go-ahead from Okoye she walks past
normal college kids chatting and on the
door it's decorated with caution tape
edgy but what I like is the blue ocean
poster regarding Plastics on the door as
the movie dives into Oceanic wildlife
and just invading it a lot just a little
call out limoncello by Og Davey and
future plays like it's coming from
riri's room it's literally blasting Riri
has a flag of Chicago a poster with math
symbols and kws statue I think it's
cause I don't really know this guy but
he has great art there's a ton of photos
around her by her bed and under the
cause statue could be a photo of her and
her mother who aren't banking on being
Cree Summers some of the photos looks
like friends and other family members
along with it we know her father is gone
and in the comics she lost her best
friend Natalie in a drive-by shooting
during a picnic so these photos those
still a little fuzzy are up to
interpretation and we love interpreting
things here in new rock stars once we
arrive at riri's garage the light shoot
up and we see the sign for safety
acronyms stay attentive for each task
you take we see the schematics for
riri's Mark 1 suit specifically her can
and outer View and it seriously
resembles the schematics needed to build
the Midnight Angel suit that shuri was
working on earlier and this is when we
recognize that that girl just met her
match there are one in the same and
riri's resources are severely sparse so
like no shade to shuri but you can't do
what she does riri's father's car she's
been fixing up is a red and black color
72 Barracuda baby the shots in the
garage kind of feel like one long Dolly
shot with no cuts and coogler loves
these it happens plenty of times in the
labs there's other things in riri's
garage I didn't really have a time to
look at heavily like the art by the
entrance or the figurines at her desk
but I'll probably be breaking it down in
the Blu-ray and maybe we'll get some
more information there as soon as they
get in they get out they're off and on
the run from the FBI they wanted but no
plays as shuri bust down the doors on
our motorcycle the barracuda license
plate reads ee-0710 which a lot of folks
on the internet have connected it to
Doom's introduction via the comics as
Sherry barrels down the street on her
motorcycle she takes a shortcut through
Cathedral of Saint Paul and Worcester
Massachusetts I'm from Massachusetts so
I'll probably pronounce that wrong and
Okoye just loves stabbing her spear
through the pavement the police blocked
the Massachusetts Avenue bridge between
Boston and Cambridge completely destroys
all the cop cars by figuring out exactly
where she had to strike the tracker in
order for it to wipe out the cop cars
and it's genius but now she's kind of a
criminal right when they think they made
it out safe a cable shoots out of the
water stabbing riri's armor and smashing
her directly into the pavement a water
grenade rolls under the Barracuda
exploding sending the car flipping along
with shuri on the motorcycle it's
terrifying it's the talokins and orca
breaches the water above the bridge and
here comes namara and some telekineal
then breaches a humpback whale with a
Tuma I am literally shook that these
whales are by a bridge near a city
ramonda did say there's more than one
and they wouldn't be alone and I'm not
sure this scene is the same whale but
when we come across scenes with some of
the orcas they're made out of fiberglass
they wanted everything to be practical
in this movie namora and atuma and the
other telekineal all speak Mayan and as
Vaz pointed out in his breakdown when
Mayan is spoken it's with blue subtitles
when akoye gets back to tell Ramona and
the council what had happened she's
promptly promptly stripped of her Rank
and as general to the door milage
co-writer Joe Robert Cole added this
line for arkoye begging to go back and
get her which doesn't sound like a koye
but the reasoning to keep it in I really
do like draw on a specific scene
um
with Angela and deny and it was a line I
remember that a question I've given
everything
and me I would have never wrote that
line because
for me I couldn't see a crash saying
that to ramonda in that Tribal Council
but it was important for her to say
because Aquarius
and it was like oh yeah sometimes people
say [__] they probably shouldn't say a
certain moments to certain people you
know what I'm saying but that's like
reality and then unlock something in
that scene okoya has given everything
but what is everything especially to
raimonda who literally just lost
everything sometimes you say dumb stuff
when you shouldn't you know it's like a
kind of child behavior actually I do it
as an adult so it happens all the time I
rewound and watch this thing singing
five times five times when making this
breakdown and I would have watched it
five more times if I wasn't writing this
but you know I had I had to stop I had
to put myself on stop I love this scene
Angela Bassett good Lord give her the
academy and the original script romanda
says have I not given everything a koi
daughter of carabo which could have been
taken out of the script maybe because
Angela bassett's performance was so good
on that first deliver they just didn't
include it in different parts of this
movie they do refer to people with their
name in their tribe or the family which
I wanted to break down for a bit so
there's no more confusion because I was
confusion we have the Border tribe which
is wakabe nataki and Okoye the River
tribe is Nokia's the mining tribe the
merchant tribe the Jabari tribe as we
know is embar shuri and Riri are taken
to the glow warm Cavern this cave right
before you enter to Logan which is
breathtaking breathtaking before it's
even shot now from the wakanda forever
podcast we learn a lot about this exact
location so I needed to understand going
back to 900 A.D
where they started and why and from 900
A.D in Chiapas Mexico after the death of
pacal a group of people migrated to the
lowlands that would be Tulum
and they then were there until the
Spanish came at that point I didn't
believe it was 1792 that's when they
went into the water so we tracked them
for 200 years in the water until they
ended up in the Puerto Rican Trench and
they were in the Haldol Zone which is
about 12 000 feet down so that's where
we placed them that's where they went we
tracked pretty much everything about
them Hannah beachler the production
designer created a 400 plus page Bible
for the teleconneal if you don't know
what a Bible is it just holds everything
about the background of that that the
people and I need it I need it and she
assisted discovering where they would
live on this dang map I love her so much
additionally Riri is always Walling
the fruit are just papayas it's nothing
crazy when Nakia is at the Yucatan
Peninsula she's wearing traditional
Yukon women clothing more so it's the
fabric behind her we see the red lady
papaya growing Hannah beechler also
mentioned they brought in people from
Guatemala to help build the set and help
them make even small changes you can
even spot the cochinita PB I'm sorry if
I pronounced that wrong I'm so bad at
this when Nikia finally gets the woman
to speak to her the woman tells her how
they call no more feathered serpent God
of this realm and the realm below Hannah
beechler talks on this especially the
art on the wall reflecting a kingdom
more every piece of painting that you
see in the memorabilia room with nemour
is a story told about him becoming a
king or Kahu ahau of telecon we interned
to Moore's Hut I say Hut because that's
exactly what it is they refer to this
room as the memorabilia room with all
the Moore's paintings which again done
by Brandon Sadler they had this man
working the painting is the Calabash
tree that looks like snakes it's six
murals along all the hieroglyphs now
like I said earlier Hannah beechler is a
boss and an icon on and study so much
history for telecon she based no More's
rise of the king off the Mayan hero
twins Who tricked the lord of the
underworld to get powers and then had
the powers to take and Restore Life and
became the Sun and Moon the Lords of
Earth she mentioned the wakanda forever
podcast no more as the god of the upper
World middle world and underworld
because he can breathe underwater walk
on land and fly in the sky in a way he
is the hero twins Hannah on Twitter also
described him More's establishment story
via the paintings on the wall and its
inspiration we're taken back to 1571 A.D
the Yucatan Namor says chalk their God
of rain and abundance gave their Shaman
a vision of what could save them and
shock led him to the blue plant under
the water remember back to the first
black panther the story of the
heart-shaped herb so its Origins are
still not off that's incredible to me
also the same way of breaking down the
plants and consuming it I love it it's
said in the original script that their
skin turns blue because it can't breathe
the skin it just can't breathe every
time they're in the water that's why
they're not blue when no more promises
to bury his mom on the surface land
according to the original script it was
1631 A.D Young no more does in fact kill
everyone there and heads back to the
water to protect his people now the Sun
and telecon is wild we all had questions
about it taken out of the original
script they explain how the Sun Works
they called it SAS tune which is the
Mayan word composed of words sass
meaning light and tune meaning Stone
they used kelp you guys they literally
used kelp no more said we create our own
plant of city and base optic fibers in
the leaves to harness the glow of algae
all of this along with a heartfelt
conversation about helping one another
was removed from the script why I have
no idea but this material gives way for
a million other theories to their son
and maybe some we can possibly come back
to in different movies additionally in
the original script shuri and reread go
to telecon to help illuminate the sun
and the tension between the more insuri
is truly insane it's a lot it's a
romantic moment before we see them
sitting in the camera talking when Nakia
finds the entrance to the cavern it's
the same entrance the shaman found all
those years ago now in this grip they
call our little boat the skirmisher
vehicle and I just think that's neat
we're at the CIA and on the screen the
pictures of ravery on campus are there
the U.S Secretary of State tells them
how the president wants to take action
against wakanda as though that's a good
idea while in the cavern Nakia literally
blasts two teleconneals certainly
killing them up close with a Sonic round
from her gun which I assume is made of
vibranium so that much would probably
kill any telekinil excluding Amore this
scene of no more descending was
discussed on the wakanda forever podcast
and truly is pretty insane how they shot
it so the idea came up to shoot
everything that we could possibly do
underwater in a tank so that we could
give WETA who's the VFX company that's
doing those underwater sequences give
them some type of reference for light
and reference for how hair how Ruth's
costumes react underwater Hannah's
colors her sets textures and you know
different materials she wants to use
underwater so at the end of the day we
shot as much as we could underwater
which you know you see in the trailer
you see him descending from the SAT soon
and he goes into this beautiful Throne
so he shot that underwater he's on wires
and we shoot that so there's a reference
underwater camera housing you know we
light it so it looks good and then we
take that and we also put it on a stage
and we had a backdrop that was printed
that had the set same kind of giving us
the color of his throne room and we
would shoot that dry so then he was
suspended in a dry environment and we
would shoot it two times in the podcast
they even refer to the sun SS Stone
additionally at one moment
glimpse of the throne room doors behind
nomura and atuma Hannah also shared the
blueprints to what that area surrounding
the Megalodon teeth looks like if you're
not following her on Twitter yet or by
the end of this please do she shares a
lot of BTS to wakanda and she's very
open about it the japari says glory to
Hahnemann and like Voss said in his
breakdown this is the ape deity that
they worship we see the new armor
Dawning it later we see the statues
outside the Jabari Outpost later as well
I feel like they've taken a lot of this
movie to expand more on their characters
and blow out the world and I really
appreciate that and I love it before all
hell breaks loose Okoye is beside
herself buying flowers at a flower shop
in the original script there's a lot of
time she actually faces not being the
general of the door melaji anymore like
this scene at the flower shop when even
the man working there says she deserves
to be the queen and she's still the
city's General they also released this
deleted scene and I want you to step
forward on behalf of the water tribe to
become Queen no one has more support
among the people than you with that
deleted scene in this one of Okoye
saying goodbye I'm here to say goodbye
will you go
whatever my new spacesuit takes me I
thought you said it was ugly oh it's
hideous
for a daughter
I'm not a daughter anymore
I think this could be setting up two
things once Okoye leaves sure he is in
Haiti and ambaku is Left To Rule wakanda
how would the people feel about all of
that being forced upon them if they
stood by a koi being the next in line to
be the queen I mean due to Sherry's
thirst for Revenge we see later that she
gets a lot of them killed fighting the
teleconil and we do know this from
Whitney's breakdown on the door milage's
midnight Angels due to all of this
tragedy and the rotating door of wakanda
leadership an anti-monarchy sentiment
began to emerge with the people of
wakanda questioning not only whether
t'challa could handle the duties of King
alongside being a superhero but whether
there should even be a king at all
coogler being a massive comic book fan
could be setting up the nation revolting
number two Okoye currently has the Mark
1 Midnight Angel suit when it needs
repairing where will she go I'm putting
my money down on Chicago and iron heart
because Riri knows how to fix anything
the ships that expander called the
Sunbird and the EMTs succumb to the
siren song when Baku screams Invaders
and it echoes that the city is being
washed away and destroyed Anika and
shuri are in the sky picking up the
transit stations full of people to Usher
them to safety ramonda and Riri begins
sending out emergency response pleats
scarab beetles which they referred to
that in the script but they are always
prepared look at them and also look at
Riri is already unnatural at this
unfortunately we know how this goes sure
he is left inconsolable originally shuri
goes off on Ikea for leaving them when
they needed her in akoye for promising
to lay her life down on the throne and
still standing by shuri's entire family
being dead which in retrospect probably
the best to leave out sure he is hurt
but I think she knows there's no use in
hurting others right now and then we're
at another funeral this time for Ramona
sure he having never burned her garments
is wearing the exact same outfit she did
for her brother I love this growth that
umbaku had since the first film it's not
competition it's honor and respect and I
love how honest he is with shuri in
regards to losing literally everything
but being there for her regardless and
looking out for her all the time we cut
back to the B feline story of Val and
Ross Val turns on the news to CNN's
Anderson Cooper reporting on Ramona's
death the ticker below says President
ritzen signed trade pact with new Asgard
to create mutually beneficial
partnership now there was a leak from
Secret Invasion be warned a little bit
of a leak a little league just plug your
ears while I say this there was a little
leak for sacred invasion of the new
president ritzen who we haven't met but
clearly is true as we can confirm it in
wakanda Forever in the original script
though Graham Lake Bell's character was
on the phone with Val and Val played the
distress call out loud to Ross she even
takes the blame for basically getting
Ramona killed these things didn't make
it into the final product of the movie
we see how much time shuri has spent
away from her lab where she tried making
synthetic new herbs the plants are dying
and fading this is the beginning of her
anger fully taken over and honestly I
can't say I wouldn't be heated as well I
love my mom she's using her science
stuff in the petri dish and I'm gonna
act like I know what those things are
before Tick Tock but I didn't really
this scene of everyone now living at the
Jabari Outpost feels like the first
movie when they go to the Jabari Outpost
for help they even made a joke earlier
about Nakia saving the day again and I'd
argue the Jabari saved the day again
when Sherry and Riri begin working
shuri's screen reads genuine just math
problems using the wakanan alphabet that
I can't solve regardless of the language
because I'm not smart but she's running
tests immediately trying to create
something to get back into more when we
see Anika's space near the river
Province I love her and I would marry
her in a heartbeat additionally again
they made everything as practical as can
be they built her house in the original
script she actually told Sherry before
no more even arrived to wakanda that she
was leaving the door milage once a koi
was stripped of her ring so like Okoye
they are both great warriors with no
concrete jobs at the moment free to do
whatever they want fight whoever they
want as Riri and sure he continued to
build study and create we get a peek at
riri's Mark II suit and genuinely it has
built-in cornrows and I'm obsessed with
it and as a helpful companion Sherry
gives notes that's when Sherry finally
cracks the code on the synthetic herb as
Yuri takes the herb the table around her
is constantly checking her vitals
pleasures of her mom in the funeral
passage she succumbs and you'd think it
was a good sign but it's truly her anger
boiling to a point which we see during
the ancestral plane when it's revealed
killmonger is waiting for her and for
someone dead in the ancestral plane he's
a dick wouldn't you want to be nice if
you're dead maybe that's just his motive
when Flames shoot up they Blaze off the
pillars that say rest in power are hero
wisdom what have you which is
interesting when she got angry with
killmonger she burned the idea of who
she truly is in the message her mother
Left Behind we're back to the ocean and
re-re-rebuilt her machine to find
vibranium but this time it shoots Sonic
Blast definitely in Metallica Neil and
like that war begins riri's new suit is
definitely reminiscent of Iron Man's at
the top it has a compass in skull and
crossbows I'd assume reflect when she's
in the danger zone she has a sonar
scouting in the area to her right and
monitors to her Photon Cannon our girl
upgraded later we even get a glimpse of
her Shields percentage damage
Diagnostics and power level just by
using her thrusters her power went from
90 to a steady decline of 78 77 76 and
going on and on and on the suit is
warning her she's using max power once
nomoro puts the hydro bomb in the ship's
Sonic emitter we see the schematics of
the ship's failing start on the one of
the wakanda naval Engineers kamoyo beats
then more teleconil troops arrive and
more Hydro bombs and whales and this is
insane on the beach Sharia Namor are
destroying each other wings are being
ripped off sure he gets stabbed by a
vibranium spear it's like nasty stuff no
more says imperious wrecks which he was
going to say in the original script much
earlier in the script is written like
we're seeing each other's POV of shuri
and Nemours flashbacks so the flashbacks
of young no more are his and wakanda's
are shuries it's so much both their moms
are there but now they're gone they're
just love their babies and I just wanted
to scream once telecon and will kind of
find an agreement we see the Golden City
is back thriving no water damage and yes
the heart-shaped herb is being grown
Where They Mourn Ramona and t'challa my
favorite girl Riri is on her way back to
America and a reminder ironheart will
pick up right where wakanda forever left
off for Riri we're back to the warrior
Falls and from the looks of most people
no style upgrade but for the door milage
since the first black panther and of
course this isn't the first time embaku
wound up at the damn Warrior Falls it's
clear unless we don't see someone
challenge him that umbaku will be our
next leader we're back to in a Moore's
memorabilia room where a new painting is
taking place incorporating the Black
Panther seeing as all these paintings
follow his life this was a Monumental
part to it he lost his wings it's
wrapped now no more saying the surface
world will come for wakanda and wakanda
will turn to us is highly probable in
the original script I mentioned this
earlier Val knew she accidentally set up
the wakanans for America's distrust so
when or if they decide to attack who
will be on their side remember the
deleted scene of Okoye no longer staying
in wakanda and her keeping the suit she
freed Ross and now the big question is
where are they going she's not going
back to wakanda and he's the Enemy of
the State in the eyes of the CIA so
these are just good questions to ask
when shuri decides to burn her funeral
garments alone in her own ritual we get
flashbacks of t'challa and shuri in the
lab from the first movie greeting each
other winning at Warrior Falls getting
the Black Panther necklace when he
enters the throne room at the end of the
first movie y'all it just makes me want
to break down but of course Rihanna had
to come in making it worse like a better
worst I love the song but it's so sad
you guys this is it for my wakanda
forever digital release break down now
the thing about breakdowns is we never
really have enough time to discuss
everything we want to so there will be
more videos later especially me going
over the Blu-ray with more BTS and
Easter eggs I didn't talk about
t'challa's son in this video because
boss approaches it perfectly in his
breakdown and again if there's anything
I'm missing it was covered in one of the
other two breakdowns we did on this
channel I just picked up a little bit of
the Lost pieces you know what I'm saying
make sure to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new Rockstar subscribe new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
wakanda forever
foreign
[Music]